and II if it's cool i wiII probably
bring Marty short out here and I do want
to get him out here because he's he's my
favorite person of all time I did want
to ask you something if it's cool okay
I'm just gonna show you this okay and be
honest okay I will
what do you think what do you think of
this hat do you think I can pull this
hat off at work oh you know what before
you wear it at work maybe watch this ad
from one of our sponsors is today the
day
can you pull off this look you've been
working up the courage to wear a new hat
to work for months now but you lack the
confidence you need because you're
afraid of the repercussions it's only
natural the bad hat contains it's a lot
a major hat fell out of Pasadena where a
Michael carpenter wore an ill-advised
cap that's why for the first time ever
Mutual of Omaha is proud to offer new
hat insurance coming today and a Mutual
of Omaha advisor will examine the hat
you plan on wearing including in depth
3d data analysis our advisors will offer
professional insight cream and burnt
sienna together that's it's a high-risk
cap be honest as well as helpful
suggestions do you play the bass no you
may want to start we'll work up a risk
profile based on your level of
sensitivity and a detailed description
of your work environment when there's
Brendan he doesn't really like me and
Jarrod finally will drop a policy that
will help mitigate the risk of a hat
related disaster not only do I have a
new hat I also have peace of mind so no
matter what happens I'm covered nice hat
dumbass
new hat insurance from Mutual of Omaha
thank you very much
you